foreign
has been on Twitter and oh my God what
he's got to say is amazing welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so if you're a Batman 5 fan you will
know that Jay and Michael's against your
JMS because it's much easier to say has
been desperately trying to get his
rebooted version of Babylon 5 back on
our screens he had it all green lit he's
written a pilot he was hoping to have a
lot of screens this year but the CW is
in absolute bloody turmoil it's in a
process of being bought out by a new
company and next star I think and
they're rebranding themselves they are
hoping to become a completely different
type of Channel now if you are a regular
side trucker you'll know that actually I
did a video a little while ago that
people I speak to have told me that it's
not going on the CW anyway and when the
B5 reboot happens it will be going
straight to HBO Max and then probably on
the CW afterwards which oh my God that
would be so much better the stuff the CW
makes is just there's a few exceptions
but most of it is absolutely trash I
would much rather see a modernized
up-to-date more grown-up version of
Apple five which I've always did deal
with some really serious grown-up
um things so I would much rather see
that on the HBO Max that it was a lot
much Brave place to put a show like that
but anyway
that's not what JMS has been talking
about on Twitter because he dropped a
bombshell a day or two ago that actually
there has been a secret project a secret
Babylon 5 project that is done is in the
bag is filmed they're just finishing off
the last few little bits but what is
this project I hear you say well JMS has
been very clear that it is not related
to The Babylon 5 reboot this has all of
the original existing original casting
so we're going to see Sheridan and
Ivanova come back
Bruce bruxleyner is one of my favorite
actors I've loved him since the
Scarecrow Mrs King days when he was a a
wee whipper snapper in the 80s
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't wait to see him come back and
he's obviously a really good still
working actor who's in the Orville
recently he's the president and he was
brilliant to go and he's got a great
voice so
obviously the fans went crazy on Twitter
and they started bugging Jameis what
what have you done what's what's going
on is it actually done are you just
teasing us and he you know he's really
good on Twitter actually he does reply
to things he repeatedly said this is a
new project it's secret I can't see
anything else that's not up to me to
reveal but I wanted to let you know that
I'm really really proud of this and I'm
really happy it's been done it will be
announced officially at Comic-Con um in
early 2023 and it will be on our screens
in 20 by the way if you like the content
please hit that join button it really
helps us out and if you're new to the
channel like subscribe hit that Bell
notification and share the video
wherever the hell you liked but what
could this project be well
I don't think it's a coincidence that
summer 2023 is the 25th anniversary of
when Babylon 5 left our screens
can you believe it's been 25 years I I'm
old enough to have watched the last
episodes and to have watched the
premiere of the movies and things it's
been 25 years
that battle five is still on our screens
it still has a really strong cult
following you know it really is amazing
it's been two and a half decades so they
could have just done a
um reunion you know got all the
surviving actors back together on a
couch that crap friends thing they did a
little while ago that kind of thing and
just gone oh look I'm brilliant bad one
five was but it looks like they've
decided to go a little bit further and
actually film something an actual
story for us to enjoy and I'm sure then
they will then have the all sitting on a
couch thing as well but if that's all
they were going to do they wouldn't have
filmed it by now would they and and so
since he was talking about finishing
touches and special effects and things
so 100 this is more far more than just
that but hopefully we'll get to see both
because I want to see the actors talking
about it as well but ah
just put it on to to JMS to no it's the
25th anniversary and to go you know what
we're not just doing that piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh sit around a table and chat
we're actually going to do a story we're
gonna actually have to do something for
fans that they will go over
um and and I will I'm obviously I'm
really excited with this Babylon 5 for
me was never just the poor man Star Trek
which is what a lot of people said about
it at the time
foreign
it was braver than Star Trek the story
lines are phenomenal don't get me wrong
it had a few little dips and Dives but
the whole Shadow War thing and then the
warlons and the get out of my Galaxy
stuff was just it actually gives you
Goosebumps it was phenomenal television
the couple of movies they did afterwards
were again phenomenal particularly the
flashback one when we saw the actual war
with the monari
um in Bari
[Music]
I just I just thought it was great
um and I I cannot wait to see what JMS
does with this
news on the reboot he says it is the
Pilot's still done he's still waiting
for news he did mention the CW again
because I think that is the official
place this is still supposedly gonna go
but as I say from what I'm being told I
have gone back to people I speak to and
said have you heard anything else and I
said no no if this happens it'll get HBO
Max first especially because of all the
reworking now it's Warner Brothers
Discovery and once all the current
mess is sort of cleaned up he's my
source says he's pretty sure this is one
of those projects that they will have
because it's the sort of thing that just
fits on HBO Max
um it'll fit perfectly
um and they're just the only thing that
they're really waiting on at the moment
um it's got nothing to do with the CW
really it's got everything to do with
the merger with Warner Brothers and
Discovery and once all that is sorted
it'll be full steam ahead so
so I don't know what you guys think but
I am seriously excited about this so
please get in the comments tell me are
you excited or are you not can you like
me and not wait to see the original cast
back I I just I just love it
um we've already seen the B5 get
decommissioned I'm wondering is there
going to be a story around that maybe
but hey let's wait and see because I
think we could say JMS is a pretty
imaginative guy and I just love that if
they're doing what we think they're
doing that they've done this for the
fans
brilliant if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification and if you really enjoy the
content please consider becoming fully
fledged side Trekker and hit that join
button thanks very much guys and as
always stay safe
by the way if you are a regular
[Music]